let's talk about the brain ventricles
these are the lateral these are the
third ventricle and these are the fourth
ventricles let's look at this in a
animated view So In A sagittal section
these are the lateral ventricles which
are the biggest ventricles in the brain
then these are the third ventricles the
lateral and the third ventricle is
connected via
a particular
Channel which is known as foramen of
Monroe
then in the sagittal view you can
clearly see the fourth ventricle it's
important to note that the fourth and
the third ventricle is connected by a
cerebral aqueduct
all these ventricles are lined by
choroid plexus these chloride plexus
secret cerebrospinal fluid which
circulates throughout these ventricles
watch the full video to know more